[Music]
welcome to the program well we've been
following a breaking news story for the
last hour or so coming to us from
austria
police have said that several people
have been killed in an attack
in the center of the capital vienna
well gunshots were heard in the city
center in what the interior minister
referred to
as a terror attack that's how it's been
categorized at the moment he said that
the incident is thought to have been
committed by
several people so more than one attacker
involved
one has been killed and more attackers
potentially on the run so this is still
a live situation that continues to
unfold
this hour witnesses are saying that all
this happened close to
vienna's main synagogue but police
haven't confirmed if it was in fact that
synagogue that was the target because
the attack was unfolding in the streets
surrounding the synagogue we do have
dominic kane on the phone he's been
following developments very closely
so several attackers thought to have
been involved one of them has been
killed
and then also now these reports uh that
several people have
also been killed in this attack dominic
yes that's right mariam we
are it's obviously it's an unfolding
situation as we speak
we know that the federal interior
minister of austria has spoken about
a perpetrator having been arrested we
know also
that he has spoken about there being
numerous wounded
and he is saying that there have been
deaths but he's not saying how many
deaths there have been
we also know that other sources which
are unconfirmed
are talking about the uh the
perpetrators of this incident of this
what is being called by the authorities
in their words a terrorist
incident that at least one of the
perpetrators
is believed to have been armed with an
automatic weapon
some are speculating that it was a
kalashnikov rifle on ak-47
and that the one of the perpetrators who
had this weapon if this is confirmed
appear to be uh firing indiscriminately
we know also
that others have witnesses have spoken
about
dozens of shots having been fired some
talking about perhaps it being 50 shots
being fired we have to be a little
cautious
about the reference to whether the
synagogue which was nearby
was in any way um the target of this
attack that has not been confirmed and
indeed
the scene of the crime is perhaps
two to three minutes walk from that
synagogue
so it would be it would be better
perhaps not to
to speculate too far so far at least in
in whether that was a target of this
attack but what is clear
is that the uh federal interior minister
of austria is talking about this as
being a
terrorist attack in his words and that
he believes that this is an
ongoing situation well clearly that
indicates
that the authorities believe that there
is more than one perpetrator involved in
this incident
but they are speaking right now purely
of one
of the perpetrators having been arrested
which would suggest perhaps
that there are there is at least one
other perhaps more than one other
at large right now and of course the
timing of all of this dominic
french police we know are investigating
the terrorist attack in nice
uh that's how that is the attack that
took place um they've
made some arrests in that case they're
questioning others we know that a 29
year old tunisian man was arrested
after that horrific attack there now
there's absolutely no suggestion
that any of these attacks are linked but
it comes at a very
tense time in the region oh there's no
question about it that
the authorities right across europe are
certainly aware of what has been taking
place as you were saying mariam
in different countries and they clearly
will be have
been very concerned that there might
have been some sort of
uh replication of that in in
austria the problem here clearly is that
while this situation is still unfolding
it is
perhaps best not to to speculate in so
far as
as possible linkages with other
incidents that have taken place
other than to speak about this more in
the sense of
the overall awareness of the situation
the overall appreciation
of the dangers that are out there and
perhaps it would be best uh to
to remind viewers what has actually
happened here we know that
the police have been involved in an
incident involving
many shots having been fired different
sources on social media have been
putting video out
of what would appear to have been the uh
parts of the incident as it unfolded
and indeed if this unverified social
media footage is to be believed
then it suggests indeed that very many
shots have been fired
what we know for certain what has been
confirmed as i say is what the federal
interior minister of austria
has said which is that at least one
perpetrator
has been arrested now in so far as other
elements that go with this particular
scenario that is unfolding right now
there is speculation again unconfirmed
from what i have seen
at any rate that one of the perpetrators
may have been
uh armed with some form of explosive
belt that is not confirmed and
uh in the time it has taken me uh to
to get to the situation to be able to
broadcast i haven't been able to confirm
that elsewhere
but in so far as as i was saying before
the general situation
there's no doubt that people that uh
that agencies intelligence agencies are
the police forces of the main
large metropolis in central and western
europe will have seen what has unfolded
in france
and will have been saying to themselves
we have to guard against something
similar happening here
but clearly as i say this is unfolding
we have that confirmation of one arrest
we have a suggestion
a suggestion only that i have seen in
the last few seconds
that perhaps uh there may be some sort
of hostage situation
unfolding again i have not seen that
confirmed
anywhere but it is being speculated upon
so that is the situation that it stands
right now but as you say
there is no doubt that many different
european intelligence and police
agencies
will have looked at what's happened in
france in recent days in recent weeks
and wondered whether perhaps something
might it might something similar might
happen here
but of course we can't link what's
happening here officially
directly with anything that's happened
in the last few weeks until there is
some confirmation
from intelligence and police sources and
eden will continue to
obviously follow uh any information that
should
emerge on this story for now thank you
very much dominic kaden we are just
looking at pictures
coming to us from the austrian capital
vienna
a shooting is underway police have just
have said that this is
a terror attack uh there have been
injuries and some people
have been killed this according to the
country's interior minister
who's been quoted by the austrian
broadcaster rftv
they said it's a terror attack there are
several perpetrators involved
one of them has been killed others are
on the run witnesses are saying that it
happened close to the city's main
synagogue
but it's not clear if the synagogue was
the target of this attack
and of course public have been cleared
from the area
as police continue with their work